[Musique]
bonjour la question est vieille comme le
monde pourquoi certains gravissent des
montagnes alors que d'autres se
découragent d'un chemin
pourquoi certains sont habités par une
énergie inoxydable alors que d'autres
sont plutôt habité par le doute et vont
compter les heures avant les week-ends
nous avons tous abandonné un projet qui
nous tenait à coeur
un objectif professionnel faire du sport
arrêter de fumer
personnellement en début de carrière
j'ai eu la chance d'exercer un métier
formidable qui m'a passionné
j'ai des radiologues mais au bout de
quelques années j'avais l'impression de
faire la même chose
à l'époque je n'avais pas compris ce
qu'étaient les motivations durable et
bien pour comprendre
nous allons observer cette montagne
c'est à 4000 m c'est un une deux mental
est plus difficile à gravir des alpes
imaginez le froid la neige le vent le
vertige le danger et par dessus tout
cette longueur interminable qui va
provoquer de l'épuisement donc c'est
déjà relativement difficile eh bien nous
allons rajouter une difficulté imaginez
que vous soyez amputé des deux bras et
des deux jambes
vous pensez que ça n'est pas possible
bien que quelqu'un l'a fait il s'appelle
jamie a dream
ce qu'il a fait est proprement
incroyable c'est surhumain
j'aurais pu aussi parler de philippe
croizon qui avec le même handicap
traversent les océans à la nage ces gens
là sont des résilient ils ont su trouver
en eux une force incroyable pour
affronter des difficultés gigantesque et
leur message est le suivant les
difficultés ne sont pas un obstacle
les difficultés même les plus
effroyables ne sont pas un obstacle
certains vont dire mais ces gens là sont
inaccessibles ils sont trop forts alors
inspirons nous de gens plus accessible
vous connaissez peut-être dans votre
entourage des personnes durement
touchées par l'âge
10 et qui malgré leurs malheurs sont
capables de diffuser une énergie une
joie de vivre et une bonne humeur
tellement communicative qu'ils peuvent
remonter le moral à des personnes plus
jeunes et en meilleure santé qu'elle
devant une fosse devant une force de
caractère
si importante il ne pouvons qu'être
admiratif et lorsque nous leur demandons
mais comment font-ils bien en général
ils ont une réponse simple et émouvante
tant que je suis vivant il ya plus de
positif que de négatif
une leçon immense donc que nous
apprennent ces personnes et bien que nos
faiblesses ne sont pas un obstacle
même le désespoir n'est pas un obstacle
bien mais certains vont me dire mais
nous devons gérer ses motivations
pendant des années année après année
sans jamais fléchir
comment faire bien c'est là que les
neurosciences vont nous donner un coup
de pouce déterminant à la base de toutes
nos actions de tous nos jugements il y a
les réseaux émotionnel et parmi ces
réseaux il ya les réseaux de la
récompense ne vous arrêtez pas la
complexité de ce schéma il est là
simplement pour nous montrer les liens
entre les émotions et le mouvement est
bien sûr réseau va donc interpréter
toutes les informations qui nous arrive
sur un mode et j'aime ou je n'aime pas
j'ai envie d'avancer où j'ai envie de
fuir et ce réseau donc va évaluer le une
amélioration attendue et une
amélioration attendue en français ça
s'appelle le désire donc c'est le réseau
les réseaux de la motivation le réseau
de la récompense le réseau du désir et
le réseau du plaisir tout cela est lié
et ce n'est pas tout vous voyez ce petit
noyau rouge lao au milieu le noyau coûts
baissent et vous voyez qu'il est relié à
une flèche jaune qui descend ce sont nos
voix motrices et donc ce réseau de
du désir et du plaisir est aussi reliée
à ce qui nous met en mouvement donc ça
n'est pas une vue de l'esprit de dire
que les nos émotions et notre motivation
c'est ce qui nous fait bouger donc le
mouvement les émotions et le plaisir
sont directement liés mais ce réseau a
un défaut il a même un énorme défaut
c'est un tyran il en veut toujours plus
toujours plus de chocolat toujours plus
d'alcool toujours plus d'argent
toujours plus de live sur les réseaux
sociaux toujours plus d'objets inutiles
que nous accumulons chez nous alors
pourquoi le temps d'habilité prenons un
exemple vous êtes tranquille sur votre
canapé vous avez une journée devant vous
avec un stop de délicieux gâteaux vos
bouteilles d'alcool préféré est un
smartphone pour traîner toute la journée
sur les réseaux sociaux et bien en
théorie vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
pour être heureux pour combler votre
réseau de la récompense n'est que des
choses que qui vont combler ce réseau
vous savez très bien qu'il n'en est rien
en fait en fin de journée au mieux vous
allez ressentir de l'ennui au pire une
impression d'échec ou peut-être même de
dégoût ou alors encore plus grave
une envie d'y revenir c'est à dire une
addiction donc ce réseau à de l'avidité
et en veut toujours tous et pour
comprendre pourquoi nous allons
descendre au niveau du neurone le fond
la fonction du neurone c'est de
transmettre l'information dès qu'il est
stimulé il transmet et bien si on le
stimule toujours de la même façon et
bien lieu de transmettre il va s'arrêter
transmet donc là c'est bizarre la
fonction de nous rendre c'est de
transmettre le stimule
il s'arrête étonnant en fait c'est tout
à fait logique depuis des millions
d'années les cerveaux des animaux et des
humains se sont programmés pour survivre
et pour survivre il faut repérer le
les dangers il faut repérer les
ressources les aliments les occasions de
se reproduire
jusque là c'est du mouvement donc les
neurones ont appris à repérer le
mouvement et toute situation stable même
positive va passer au deuxième plan
c'est pour cela que au niveau de notre
réseau de la récompense même une
satisfaction très autres comme par
exemple un gros salaire ou bien une
belle villa s'ils sont stables pendant
plusieurs années
vous finirez par mois les voir et par
voir plutôt les inconvénients
donc ce réseau en veut toujours plus et
on peut mais on peut étendre cette
notion au couple imaginez que vous
fassiez toujours les mêmes choses que
vous racontiez toujours les mêmes
histoires
il se peut qu'au bout de quelques années
s'installe une légère lassitude voire
même que vous ne finissez par ne plus
voir que les défauts de l'autre tu sais
pas si ça vous parle mais cela peut
évoquer quelque chose à certains d'entre
nous donc sur des on veut toujours plus
et comment le contenter eh bien nous
allons faire appel à une propriété de du
réseau de la récompense que l'on voit
ici s'activer en orange sur cette irm et
cette propriété s'appelle d'amener
neuronale commune et bien
qu'est ce que cela signifie c'est à dire
que ce réseau va être stimulée par des
sources extrêmement différente mais
avoir va avoir une réponse similaire
pour ses sources différentes c'est pour
ça qu'on parle de monnaies neuronale
commune alors les sources différentes ça
peut être ça peut être de l'argent ça
peut être des chocolats donc des sources
matériel mais ça peut être aussi des
satisfactions immatériels comme par
exemple un sourire donner ou recevoir un
sourire ou bien avoir l'impression
d'avoir bien fait son travail
donc là on obtient quelque chose
d'intéressant les satisfactions
matérielles
le chocolat l'alcool l'argent bien au
bout d'un certain temps ce sale a
plafonné
on peut pas les multiplier à l'infini
soit on a un plafonnement soi même on a
même des problèmes alors qu'un sourire
un travail bien fait merci on peut le on
peut le renouveler tous les jours donc
comment trouver ses satisfactions
immatériel qui sont renouvelables
eh bien il ya plusieurs modèles un
modèle est intéressant celui de richard
ryan et edward deci qui ont relié nos
ses motivations personnelles ils ont
appelé les motivations intrinsèques
puisqu'elle ne dépend que de nous les
ont relié à nos besoins psychologiques
de base et ils les ont classées en trois
catégories le premier besoin c'est le
besoin d'être aimé appartenir à une
famille appartenir à une équipe
professionnelle une équipe sportive à un
groupe d'amis donc le besoin de tisser
des relations d'enrichir des relations
de qualité
le deuxième besoin c'est celui de
d'apprendre de comprendre le monde
d'explorer le monde de résoudre des
problèmes de montée en compétence
donc ce besoin de comprendre est aussi
un besoin psychologique de base et c'est
une de nos motivations un procès et le
troisième c'est besoin d'autonomie le
besoin de faire que nous avons envie de
faire le besoin de créer par exemple ça
va être un artiste ou un artisan qui
vont créer une oeuvre un objet ça peut
être un expert comptable qui va boucler
un dossier
ça peut être aussi en chef d'entreprise
qui jour après jour on va développer sa
boîte
donc ces trois groupes de motivation la
fecq l'autonomie et la compétence vont
pouvoir nourrir notre besoin de sens le
besoin de trouver un sens à notre vie
que ce soit dans les actions tous les
jours ou pour des projets de vie nous
avons besoin de soin de trouver du sens
et donc ces trois groupes de motivation
intrinsèque vont pouvoir nourrir ce sens
d'autre part ces motivations va être
conforme à nos valeurs puisque par
définition c'est nous qui les choisit
son essai nous qu'il est déterminant
pour simplifier pour résumer je les ai
résumé en trois verbes aimé faire et
comprendre mais derrière ces trois
verbes vous allez mettre vos propres
mots d'abord parce que vous êtes unique
vous seul savait les liens que vous avez
envie de développer ce que vous avez
envie d'aimer qui vous avez envie
d'aimer vous seul savez ce qui vous fait
plaisir d'apprendre
vous seul savez ce que vous avez envie
de créer jour après jour
donc c'est ses motivations vous allez
mettre vos propres mots mais également
vous allez vous en souvenir
vous allez les mémoriser pourquoi parce
que ce n'est pas quand le soleil brille
et que la route est droite que vous en
aurez besoin
c'est en période de tempête quand vous
avez envie d'abandonner quand vous êtes
découragé épuisé quand vous douté quand
vous êtes anxieux
c'est à ce moment là qu'il va falloir
vous rappelez ces trois verbes et les
mots que vous utilisez et face à une
difficulté vous verrez que vous aurez
plus envie d'avancer
alors ces trois groupes de motivation
ont également trois avantages le premier
avantage c'est qu'elles sont
intrinsèques et comme leurs noms
l'indiquent est donc celle sans emprunt
c'est qu'elles ne dépendent que de vous
elles ne dépendent pas des difficultés
extérieures
il peut vous arriver les pires ennuis
vous pouvez avoir les pires échecs des
gens peuvent se détourner d'eux vous
bien ses motivations sont toujours là
c'est votre force intérieure
jamy andrieu et philippe croizon le
savent bien des problèmes
ils ont affronté mais leur motivation
elle était là donc ses motivations vont
pouvoir vous accompagner quelles que
soient les difficultés
le deuxième avantage et c'est le sait le
l'immense mérite des neurosciences de
nous montrer c'est que ses motivations
sont renouvelables elles vont pouvoir
alimenter ce tyran cet ogre qui en veut
toujours plus tous les jours nous
pouvons aimer plus apprendre plus tous
les jours nous pouvons créer quelque
chose qui nous fait plaisir donc ses
motivations vont être presque
inépuisable tous les jours nous pouvons
trouver des motivations qui nous aide à
avancer et qui nous aide à affronter les
difficultés et le troisième groupe
ses motivations son personnel
vous seul savez ce qui vous fait vibrer
ce qui vous enthousiasme
ce qui vous donne envie de sauter de
joie ou tout simplement ce qui vous
intéresse et vous donne envie de
progresser
mais ce n'est pas si simple il va
falloir aller en vous rentrez en vous
plonger en vous afin de déterminer quels
sont ces prêts de ses motivations
profondes celles qui vous donne vraiment
envie d'avancer
il va falloir dépasser les motivations
superficielle de matériel et donc pour
cela c'est un vrai travail sur soi comme
comme nous l'indiquent le fronton du
temple de delphes connais toi toi même
ça n'est pas si simple il faut vraiment
prendre le temps de le faire et mettre
vos propres mots donc finalement
pourquoi certains gravir des montagnes
bien ils ont compris que face aux
montagnes de difficultés face aux
montagnes des forts que nous
nous avons tous à fournir dans nos vies
eh bien il faut aller mobiliser des
montagnes de désir et de plaisir de
progresser mais pas dans n'importe
quelle direction progresser en aimant
plus progressant progresser en créant
plus et progresser en apprenant plus
aimé faire et comprendre
rappelez vous ces trois verbes et
utiliser les fait face à chaque
difficulté
vous aurez plus envie d'avancer et pour
terminer si on met ces trois vers
l'ensemble aimé faire comprendre et bien
aimé faire comprendre des idées
nouvelles
c'est exactement la motivation de toutes
ces équipes de tedx to c et b to c
bénévoles formidable qui travaillent
pour ces journées des knicks mais c'est
aussi ma motivation intrinsèque
principal c'est pour cela que je suis
devant vous aujourd'hui et c'est pour
cela que je vous remercie du fond du
coeur